what i work on is regeneration
in one of the x-men movies we have jean
grey and she's throwing
all of her powers out of wolverine he's
getting all cut up
and his superpower is regeneration
as much as jean grey is you know like
ripping parts off of his body
he just can just grow it all back so
when i was doing my phd
i was really interested in this kind of
special type of worm that you can see
here in this video
that i think is even more impressive
than wolverine
so these are marine worms they live in
the ocean
specifically around bermuda and they
have this amazing ability of whole body
regeneration
so what does that mean in this video i'm
holding a knife and i'm carefully
cutting the animal into three pieces and
after you cut them
each of these pieces actually survive
you can see that they're continuing to
swim around
and amazingly they can even grow back
so if you let these pieces hang out for
a little while each of them will
regenerate any parts that are missing
um the piece that was swimming around
that with the head can regenerate the
tail
the piece that was swimming around that
was the tail can we generate you know
the middle parts in the head
and the piece that was swimming around
that was the middle section
can regenerate both the head and the
tail and this i think is
really really impressive especially
given that
normally in the wild each of these worms
has
unique pigment patterns but they've
managed to regenerate the correct
pigment pattern like where to put their
stripes
so these worms are called the panther
worm i also worked on
another type of worm uh which is called
a planarian flat worm
and they have these cute little googly
eyes um in their
scientific name is mediterranean and
just like
the panzer worm when you cut them up
they can fully regenerate
all of their pieces which is really i
think amazing these pieces
have to be put in the exact right place
so
you know let's take this worm they have
a head on the side of their body a tail
on this side of their body
and they need to figure out where to put
it so we actually know some of the
things that allow them to know where to
put it and the reason we know that
is because we can change it and when we
change it they no longer know where to
put their head and where to put their
tail
so for example the genes that say this
is tail
if we get rid of that gene it no longer
knows where to put a tail
and then it thinks it's just supposed to
put a head everywhere
and so instead of you know making this
nice normal looking worm
it puts the head everywhere so it puts a
head here and puts a head here and puts
a head here
and then you get these sort of like
monster looking worms each head thinks
it's the most important head and is
trying to drive the worm in that
particular direction
so one of the other special things about
the worms
um that i haven't talked about yet is
their reproductive organs
so for example this is a special picture
of one of these panther worms and if you
cut it right here
you're gonna get rid of all of its
eggs and sperm which live up here and
yet they can make them back
the fact that they can regenerate their
eggs and their sperm
and the cells that can make eggs and
sperm is
really really amazing and the reason why
now i'm especially interested in
figuring out how you make
eggs and sperm is because eggs and sperm
which we sometimes call collectively as
the germ
cells are immortal the germ cells the
egg and sperm because they are the
things that come together to make a new
egg
keep going on forever and so i want to
figure out
how you make those cells that never ever
ever die
they just keep on going and going and
going and now what i'm doing is i'm
actually
looking in the fruit fly and i'm trying
to figure out in the fruit fly
if you get rid of all of its germ cells
can it regenerate them and if you can
make a cell
that wasn't a germ cell before immortal
then what does that actually mean
about cellular immortality and maybe
person immortality
but i'll be sure to update you all when
i know a little bit more
you